about you know I've been physically
attacked by the left not the right
I've been I've been people are right now
taking a quote from voxcom to make it
seem like I am an anti-semite so they
can get me removed from my bank account
and stuff that's not coming from
conservatives it never has that's even
one that's totally fair but I guess what
support I will go through these videos I
will juice so I forgive me and I
actually don't need you to do an
accounting of each video but for me it's
more if I look at your channel and 85%
is criticisms that are what I would
consider relatively niche in terms of
their existence on the left it doesn't
strike me as someone whose priorities
are sent there left to say well know
what I think 85% of my channel should be
but here's the thing
Elsie Gabbard denounced identity
politics outright with Michael Tracy she
said straight up it's divisive it's bad
for us
okay identitarian ism is one of the
biggest things that i have a problem
with due to my my hit my family history
being like i know it's kind of a mean
but mix and this comes from when we look
at a firm isn't that identity politics
you're saying your view on this is
informed you're against identity
politics as informed by your identity
yeah it is what it is I'll put it this
way I am not permitted at left nor the
right allow me an identity so what that
does is it kind of ostracized me and
what I find recluse it not recluse but
what I find safe harbor I guess is the
fact that the US actually had
protections against discrimination based
on race in these things so for me
someone who's experienced it from both
directions I'm apprehensive towards
either direction when I have the left
telling him a white male on the right
telling me I'm a mudblood like I'm gonna
be fine but Tim so so I have the I have
the left saying I'm not Jewish I'm white
and I have white privilege and I have
the right thing I'm not white I'm Jewish
and Jews are a race that is really bad
and we should be really so the fact but
that doesn't make me all of a sudden say
I'm gonna do 85 percent of my videos and
criticize the left you know what I mean
no I think it's what you personally find
important right you know if you watch
any of my videos like so here's the
thing yeah subject matter doesn't
dictate politics simply because you've
got you know who's and again it's my
opinion but when I say who's trying to
remove people from the internet
it's not it's not like Nancy Pelosi it's
a particular sect of a group of
progressive more far-left individuals
who's trying to get people removed from
their banks who's trying to get people
banned who's arguing in favor of
regulation that restricts speech it's
not conservatives and it's not moderate
Democrats okay but a lot really up
specifically to that issue but let's not
be labor it I do find it sort of
interesting though that in the same
sentence that you said you're against
identity politics and that's why you
like Tulsi you made an identity politics
argument based on your identity which
strikes me as a contradiction of sorts
that's that well there is that was weird
to me there's the support of politics
based on someone's identity and the
support of a pote like our and
opposition to that right I don't
the and and let me make clear some
identity politics are absolutely a good
thing it's identitarian ism that's a bad
thing so okay I made us so I tell people
this authority is a good thing like when
a doctor tells you hey there's someone
injured put your hand on the wound
that's true Authority you'll just do it
you know they're right okay what
authoritarianism is a really really bad
thing so telling telling someone in our
society you cannot factor in race in in
terms of public accommodation that's a
violation of civil rights I like that
when you say we're absolutely going to
factor in race I don't like that so it
is it's nuanced I guess right and does
anyone who's saying that we have to
factor in race when it's not a relevant
the ACLU when they supported affirmative
action at Harvard which lumps all Asians
Indian Chinese laotians into one
category and I find that offensive as an
Asian person and so when I come out and
simply Tim claim that's an identity to
say you should be able to argue whether
it's offensive or not offensive right or
not right without saying because you are
part Asian you fight like that's
identity politics which you claim to be
against I know I agree and I think I
think the clarification then I think
what we're discovering here is that it's
not so much the core idea of identity
politics it's the application of in ways
that either is reductive or
authoritarian so